malnutrition she probably got a little
was there water in this diet she just
wasn't drinking how long how long how
long was she I think we forgot water
here
I'm gonna tell you very inspiring story
of health and weight loss about this uh
Chinese influencer hold on tell me while
I eat this donut yeah
eat that donut I'm starting my diet
tomorrow oh you're on the start tomorrow
let's go
uh inspire me on the do you on the doian
channel uh that she made for her weight
loss Journey she was like documenting
all this like Diet stuff she's going
through she went on a diet of coarse
grains cabbage eggs and fruit pretty
good right for losing weight yeah for
sure you think that's good okay good
um and then she entered a workout
regimen
at a weight loss camp that she had
joined where she's like working out uh
in the morning and then working on the
evening and then just rinse and repeat
over and over and with her goal to lose
220 pounds wow what is she gonna have
left disappear yeah 220 she's like 400.
yeah I think it's like oh oh it's up
there yeah I don't it doesn't have the
exact way but can someone even be 400
pounds yeah yeah they got a show about
people that are 600 pounds damn we're
Americans are pushing the limits do you
like that diesel chopped dog she's
Chinese you said Chinese yeah Chinese
over there right yeah Chinese over there
damn I don't know that it's that big
over there yeah I thought it was illegal
yeah bro did you know the average weight
for an American woman was like 170 170
yeah I saw that and then like but five
four oh
but I mean the average weight for Asian
American woman is still like 130
something oh okay we're doing it isn't
it like 30 or 40 percent of America is
overweight yeah yeah it's a good chunk
no yep what do you think about this diet
of uh grains cabbage eggs and fruit and
then working out twice a day well I feel
like if you have that much weight to
lose I think that's a good place to
start you know well not to start I think
you have to gradually move into it I
just use the bump over protein though
yeah for sure if she's my client of like
you're not taking that protein unless
you're just copying him yeah yeah I
would tell you know I would say actually
less protein actually I would say yes no
but I think what it really comes down to
is meeting people where they're at when
it comes to like helping people weight
loss so the fact that she's been able to
do all that off the Jump
that's pretty gangster pretty gangster
huh it's not the it's not the norm buds
yeah honestly
vacation well when you have that much
weight to lose like I think you have to
do a lot more interventions like this to
get a good chunk of the weight off and
then making sure that she could like
maintain it is probably like I feel like
Ryan's setting you up for something do
you reckon do you recommend these
weightless camps
just say yes he's gonna set you up
yes why not well because I've had some
clients that have done like the weight
loss camps in um like the states like
embarrassing [__] or what is that like
the camp or all these other
transformation spots and like they have
they lost the weight but they don't
really have a program to help them like
keep the weight off because it's super
intense off the jump right so keeping
the weight off is harder arguably than
losing it yeah because it's a longer
game because I think most people think
about like I just have to lose this
amount of weight and once I lose this
amount of weight I'm good but in reality
it's like Fitness is a lifestyle diet
it's a lifestyle but it's true though it
is true it is very true yeah like this
donut is my lifestyle but but honestly
like finding a way to like balance those
foods and finding your way to like
understand the principles of not gaining
weight and maintaining weight I think is
really important but if people don't
have that then they're more likely to
fall off the The Wagon like a 30-day
boot camp is easier than a one-year diet
100 100 people don't want to play the
long game especially if you like live
somewhere else and you're like confined
to those because once she goes back to
work and when she does regular life
stuff or is she gonna be able to work
out twice a day is she gonna be able to
maintain that diet for extended periods
let's see I mean she has an update uh
where she's at now you want to read that
that's the last thing right there oh she
died
[Laughter]
all right the fruits and Grains and eggs
and cheese
malnutrition she probably got a little
was there water in this diet she just
wasn't drinking how long how long was
she I think we forgot water here yeah
how long was she doing that that diet
for I I don't know she just had um it
doesn't say how long she was doing it
but she was she was in the middle of
doing it and then it says that like uh I
think in the situation here they're
blaming the boot camp for kind of uh I
guess for like giving her unrealistic
expectations on how fast she would lose
it yeah and pushing it too hard that's
the game because they play the
transformation thing right like oh this
person lost this amount of weight in
like three months 120 pounds or whatever
like something crazy and then they could
Market that to their people and be like
look how look at this exactly because
then their game is the short game it is
they don't I think it's a numbers game
too for a lot of these like businesses
but I think when you do like weight loss
camps I think you have a responsibility
to like you know yeah it is tough on
both sides because
um like let's say I'm the client I'll go
to Nick and I'm like hey I want to lose
like 100 pounds and he's legit right he
goes it might take eight months to a
year for sure right they don't want to
hear it
yeah I go to the next door
six weeks six week boot camp I sign up
yeah yeah you guys are way better so
it's like it's both it's on both ends
it's like people want things now yeah
especially more than ever so coaches try
to deliver now right right and then by
coach I think like good coaches like
Nick try to like go like get rid of the
now mindset and how do we change the
whole lifestyle right and but the thing
is it's like now it's like as a coach do
you stick to your morals and then almost
lose business
or do you throw away your morals and
increase business and where's the fine
line and then there's also the education
aspect it's really hard really really
hard what are some ways where let's say
you you were in charge of a client like
this that let's say that she weighed uh
450 and she wanted to lose 220. what's
something that you absolutely have to
like keep
um I guess like habit of so that she
doesn't die like for instance like
what's the thing that you're like okay
you have to make sure you do this so
that you don't just fall over and drop
dead well I think it depends on
if you have someone who's 450 the issue
the problems that they might have on
nutrition standpoint is gonna be very
different for someone who's like 220 and
like vice versa like it depends on like
how much weight they're trying to lose
can you imagine if she's like I'm 220 I
want to lose 220. you're like do you
want to disappear that's not how
subtraction it was
so like someone who's four fish on my
soul left you gotta figure out you got
to figure out how they can just move
meaningfully without like yeah you know
do anything too crazy what do you think
they messed up on the camp here probably
the the duration and how how intense
they made everything I think that has
something to do with it did they have
doctors on site or like somebody who's
constantly checking their vitals and
making sure that I think they were
supposed to uh because dude a lot of
these weight loss camps I'm not saying
like
it's just like 15 different stations of
exercises and you're like all right do
everything and you go and you're you're
yelling at these people and you're like
[__] go what are you a piece of [__]
like it's kind of like boot camp like
obviously they're not yelling them like
that but like they do just make them go
go go go and then the run down and then
they eat way lower calories and they
come back and they train again and it's
so different from their normal life that
like I don't know it just might be too
much too soon like twice a day workouts
like some athletes don't even do two a
days you know so it's like right how you
can expect someone who and that's going
off of none of that lifestyle whatsoever
yeah and also too it depends on how
gradual the change was right I think
that has to come into play but most of
the time it's like we'll see you next
week you're ready to start cool and then
they hit the ground running because it
is depending on who you talk to as well
it is a good benefit to get a client to
lose a good amount of weight in their
first couple of weeks because it helps
the momentum amount of the psychology
part yeah that's you you want them to
rack up small easy wins right so if they
see that they lose
like five pounds in the first week which
is very it can be very likely for
someone who's like
420 or something yeah then
that's a win I mean couldn't you just do
let's just focus on diet for the first
month yeah and then maybe just a walk
around the block and that's and just
stick with that's literally what you
would have to do a lot of people can't
even do that [__] but people you have to
appreciate that but yeah that too but
then the other side is this isn't enough
for me you know like I need to be doing
more yeah so it's like you have to kind
of manage their expectations a lot yeah
that's that's you see that guy who
fasted water fasted for like over a year
he was obese he was like 100 for over a
year and stand yeah he was so fat and
then he just went on this like fasting
challenge you know supposed to just be
like a couple days or whatever and he
just kept going and going and everyone's
like this guy's not gonna die he didn't
die no I think he had like salt and
water he had like enough things
yeah but he had enough fat on his body
to survive a whole year plus and he lost
all that weight and so he periodically
just goes on these like month-long fast
and [__] and then monthly meat food
that's what I thought but no it's like
it's he's been monitored scientifically
like documented it's like straight up
I was like I could only go like maybe a
few weeks without food in like three
days without water dude you ever see
that show um but he was like [__] he
was so big you ever said I forgot I'm
forgetting the name but they they send
like Wildlife experts in the wild and
like Canada or something they make them
stay out there for as long as they can
and you see people like their strategy
is I'm gonna gain as much weight as I
can before I start oh so then they could
sustain themselves and guys are coming
in like 300 pounds and those guys could
Outlast and they don't they may not have
the best survival skills but they might
Outlast everyone else who might be
because of their fat clean yeah so they
can kind of sustain them because them
getting a meal is very tough that if you
get berries and you have to eat like
[__] so many berries to get like 100
calories and then while you're trying to
build and you're walking around trying
to hunt set things up you're burning
calories constantly and you're not
getting anything else but then they
slowly get Slimmer and Slimmer as The
Show Goes On yeah but it's kind of an
interesting like experiment for people
to understand like
kind of how weight loss can happen
obviously you're not going to [__]
starve yourself and that's not what we
want to do but just from like a like a
understanding how that works so it's
kind of cool but yeah I for not
everybody should be uh fasting for a
vlog you know Jesus yeah I saw this clip
um you know how all these fat shows are
coming out and this lady's at the
hospital she's at a she's telling the
doctor like I think I need to eat I
haven't ate all day and he goes oh no
it's okay you you already ate for
several years worth of this [__] up
and then she goes yeah but I can't eat
the food at this hospital he goes no the
hell the hospital food is nutritious
it's okay it goes but it doesn't taste
good here
[Music]